[Music]
[Applause]
we'll get some more phone calls coming
up he's Peter King the uh great
columnist football morning in America
and contributor to a football night in
America all right Pete let me start with
the news here Ian Rapaport saying bill
bleek's got a second interview with the
Atlanta Falcons um do you think this is
maybe a foregone conclusion that's the
best place for
belich I don't know Dan I mean you tell
me you tell me now whether if you were
Jeffrey lurry and Howe Roseman right now
you tell me who do you want to coach
your team next year I I I mean I
understand that it's crazy to fire a
coach 11 and a half months after he had
his team in the Super Bowl I get it but
you saw what happened to the Eagles you
listen to Jaylen Herz after the game in
which he gave probably the most lukewarm
milk toast endorsement of a coach that
you could possibly give and you tell me
there's not some issues there that plus
the fact that Jaylen Herz played Just
laconic football at the end of the year
I don't know what to call it I can't
figure it out but that word comes to
mind um I guess if Atlanta is going to
sprint
out and you know go out there and and
really try to seal up Bill bellachic I
suppose they'll get him but Seth
Wickersham had a great post on social
media I think it was yesterday where he
said remember how all these teams didn't
go after Tom Brady when he was a free
agent and some of them really regret it
Dan I'm telling you to this day I
believe the 49ers sincerely regret
it um and you know so I don't know what
to say other than you can find all the
ways to criticize bellich the way you
can find ways to criticize Tom Brady you
know four years ago but I mean it's Tom
Brady it's bill bellich so I don't know
I do think some teams are going to have
regrets if the Falcons swoop in and and
sign him the Cowboys decide to keep Mike
McCarthy uh with Bill bich out there uh
how surprising is that to upgrade your
coaching
position you know look if you've won 36
regular season games in three years I
think you have a great argument to stay
regardless of what happens in the
postseason
but you know Dan look at three years in
a row how their season has ended it
crashed and burned in Dallas against the
49ers two years ago uh when Dak and
McCarthy screwed up the clock at the end
of the game it crashed and burned in an
ugly loss at San Francisco which they
couldn't do anything on offense and then
you know look at what happened in San
Francisco this year they lose
42-10 so you win 12 games but does
anybody really feel at the end of this
season whatever however you feel about
how they were just absolutely manhandled
by the seventh seed in the NFC whatever
you feel does anybody feel they're close
to the 49ers I don't so I don't know to
me I thought Jerry Jones was going to
look at this and say we need shock
therapy we're a good team but we're not
going to win with this current
Administration but Jerry decided
otherwise yeah trying to figure that out
the 12 wins is great and they could have
12 wins next year but it doesn't mean
anything unless you do something in the
postseason you could win nine games and
go to the Super Bowl but yeah you know
hey we got 12 wins okay how dangerous
are you when you get to the postseason
and you lose at home and you lose to one
of the youngest teams that we've had in
recent history and a quarterback making
his postseason debut and you were never
in that game I mean crazy thing is Dan
to me when I think about that game I
just think that that had to be one of
the most embarrassing games that Dan
Quinn has ever run a defense for and you
know you look at the end of this season
I think the last whatever eight or nine
games I figured it out the other day
they've allowed 25 points a game and 353
yards yeah this is not I mean it was a
shocking development no question but
that Cowboys defense has looked like the
Eagles defense over the last six or
seven weeks and I don't know what that
means really I just know that you know
just the same way I was shocked that
Jonathan Ganon got the job in Arizona
last year coming off a game in which his
defense gave up two of the softest
touchdowns in Super Bowl history uh to
lose the Super Bowl and then three days
later he's being produced as the coach
of the Cardinals and again look Jonathan
ganon's a good coach don't get me wrong
so maybe it shouldn't matter Dan Quinn's
a good coach maybe it shouldn't matter I
can't figure out how you pull an
absolute no-show in that game and that's
what the Dallas defense did talking to
Peter King uh I don't know other
candidates who have been uh reported
with Seattle other than Dan Quinn uh are
there who else is in play for the
Seattle Seahawks
that's a really good question they've
kept it very close to the vest I think
they're in no hurry I think they're
doing this the right way quite honestly
John Schneider he's not going to be uh
forced into doing anything I think the
best guy for that job without any
question is Mike Vel Mike Vel will be
perfect with a guy like John Schneider
because John Schneider is a really good
Personnel guy he'll find a quarterback
for Mike Vel all he all Mike Vel has to
do is go and replicate the legion of
boom and I'm exaggerating there but Mike
Vel is a really really good defensive
coach can build a good defense and even
when there's nothing to play for look
what happened with against Jacksonville
they played that game like it was the
seventh game of the World Series that's
what you want in your head coach that's
what was lacking to me with Nick serani
over the last six weeks we had Albert
Breer on last hour and he said that he
feels like the Chargers job is Jim
Harbaugh if he wants it what do you
think I think it is too the Chargers
have to do it Dan there's no question
about it they they don't have a choice
they have just gone from you know hiring
an inexperienced head coach in Brandon
Staley and it didn't work and now
they're in some trouble
with a quarterback who's a franchise
quarterback and all you ever do is go
500 there on average I think they need
the fire alarm is going off in their
building and they need help and I do
think that uh Harbaugh is going to be
the guy just assuming that they can get
the contract done the Washington job
with the number two pick
overall um I it feels like that's a
really good opport opportunity to step
into but you would know better than I
would of what they're are they going to
get an established coach a former coach
I I think it's more likely they get an
offensive brain I think when I sort of
project all of these
jobs the one person for that job who I
think would be ideal is Ben Johnson from
Detroit you see what he's done with
Jared gof he's done a fantastic job with
golf golf was so tremendous the other
night I was in the building and I just
I'll just tell you this there there was
a
tenseness at the start of that game
there was that place I I wrote it in my
column at one point they have one of
those decibel meters and the decibel
meter was at 118 I mean that's louder
than Seattle or maybe just as loud now
it's a dome but that is the same noise
that you hear if you were standing which
we would never do if you're standing on
the runway and a
737 is taking off and you're right there
as it passes by that's what the noise
was and it it never stopped Dan Quinn
told me 75 minutes before the game the
hair on the back of his neck is standing
up because he's never been in an
environment like that at that point
before the game but I think Ben Johnson
would be a really good candidate they're
going to take a quarterback number two
almost certainly
so let Ben Johnson work with you know
one of those guys Drake May penck Caleb
Williams whatever happens and that's
what I would do if I were
them the odds of Carolina getting an
established
coach I mean Dan who wants to coach in
Carolina let's be
honest I mean who wants to go to work
for David terer tell me I I I would like
to know there's a lot of people who
would say oh I'll take that job and and
and and look they'll get somebody good I
mean if I were them I'd go hard after
Lou an aruma He got job last year he is
an excellent football coach he will
build a great defense and he'll figure
it out on offense but I think Lou
anarumo would be a great choice there
he'd established some toughness right
away some
credibility but I also think that they
have to be looking at somebody to
Salvage Bryce young and look I'm so
tired of hearing Bryce Young's a bust
what a terrible Choice all that stuff
how would you know if you're running for
your life every snap I mean it's
ridiculous to say that Bryce Young's a
waste it's stupid and he still has a
chance I think to be really good in the
NFL they just have to prioritize the
offensive line above
all the situation with the Colts with
Jim ERS obviously sensitivity there but
the the
NFL how do you handle something like
that with Jim Jim 's Health
situation if indeed that it is uh
substance abuse
related I think they have to treat this
uh with some care I mean obviously
they'll treat it with care but they also
have to treat it like you know you can't
have different rules for an owner that
you have for you know a coach or a
player and in my opinion I think the NFL
is going to have to find a way to
massage this and to gently find a way to
make sure he gets x amount of treatment
and that there is probably at some point
some discipline involved if it is what
it appears to be but again I think we're
so early in the story uh we may end up
finding out that it isn't what everybody
says it is right now so I think we have
to be cautious about making any final
judgment on that right now good to talk
to you Pete safe travels this weekend
thank you hey all the best Dan good to
talk to you that's Peter King football
morning in America columnist contributor
to football night in America